hey guys how's it going welcome back to
my summer snack series I'm Justine
everyday this week I'm making a sweet
summer treat some of the things
recommended by you guys than others I
just found them on the internet today
we're gonna be making a cappuccino
cooler I am obsessed with coffee and
this little treat looks right on my
alley so these are all the items that
we're going to be needing whipped cream
chocolate ice cream chocolate syrup
crushed ice which is in the freezer and
also chilled coffee which is also in the
freezer and it's still warm we'll give
it a few more minutes while I prepare
the other items first thing we need is
one and a half cups of chocolate ice
cream I mean I'm not gonna measure it so
this is a one and a half cup I just want
to see how much that is I also don't
wanna mess this up because I think this
is gonna be really good and we'll put a
little extra in just for taste so you
could probably even make this with
vanilla ice cream if you wanted 1/4 cup
of chocolate syrup I feel like that's
kind of excessive ever no use your best
judgement liked about a 1/4 cough so
we've got our ice cream and the coffee
which is not quite chilled that's
alright
we'll just put it in here and then we're
gonna blend this up ready for the blend
get yourself some glasses I don't have
any crushed ice so we're gonna just use
some basic cubes okay ready
oh that looks fantastic uh perfection
add some whipped cream
and I'm gonna add a little bit of this
chocolate syrup just because because I
can and of course last just add a little
straw okay here it is cappuccino cooler
Oh My Goddess have seen in this nobody I
know
mmm chocolatey it's so delicious
it tastes like a chocolate milkshake
what is it it's a cappuccino cooler ice
cream coffee healthy healthy thank you
so much for watching I hope you've been
enjoying the summer snack series I've
been having so much fun making these
videos and surprisingly not messing
things up too terribly ladies and
comments below on what you think I'm
gonna be making tomorrow and if you were
right about the video that I made
yesterday you can brag about it in the
comments looks like Jenna's not drinking
this so that's just line